31 year old watching tick tocks let's do
this
i don't know why i never seen a plant
grow before but this
this blew my mind
it just go it's just a seed
nature is amazing just wait for it
seriously
there he goes there he goes the best
part here comes hold up props to the
cameraman for standing there for 87
days okay all right okay here it comes
it comes oh a flower you think great it
dies
right away so sad
but wait
it just comes out like that
from the oh
i'm never eating an eggplant no
no that's disgusting phil
oh gosh uh have you seen the mushrooms
feels like i'm doing that for this
company but it blew my mind
it's so disgusting nature is gross i'm
done with nature
canceling look at this
they just come out
so freaky i don't like it
at all so you think they're soft right
but no they're
ugh yuck stop it i'm never eating a
mushroom
god damn it i slept weird and i can't
move my neck now this is great
anyhow moving away from plant tic-tac
let's move on to
filter turns anything green to purple
wow and since we have a very green
backyard
i thought i would try it the filter it
changes green to purple
no way it did it so this film
nice backyard that's an awesome backyard
greenest backyard i've ever seen
my god this is the problem with
tick-tock and it's so
annoying all right everyone makes the
same
goddamn tick-tock oh this filter turns
green from part to purple
here we go oh look wow
this filtered the fire it did it
wow green to purple
show us your goddamn backyard i thought
i would try it
people complain about my videos huh all
right
all right well oh i remember why i saved
this because this guy is just here
chilling
is that the guy the man the myth
don't tell me the legend used to make
cringe i can't send this
that's 7 million likes let me try it
[Music]
why dude is handsome smiling i don't
can get it mate you know what hair ties
how did it work you were supposed to be
the chosen one
this is interesting i never heard
someone be so wrong
[ __ ] idiots this is what great about
tic tock they have so many dumb people
let's see if we got some uplifting
pickpock content
[Music]
that guy's gonna go places christian
ronaldo is shaking
the wealthiest man is not the man who
has the most
is the man who needs the least
you have a great day on your terms be
more
consumers thank you boromir
i hope you can make it out of that bush
one day
[ __ ] i saved so much money watching that
tick tock
oh this is amazing can someone explain
to me my indian bros calling all indian
brush
what is happening here what is he doing
why is he acting like he did the coolest
thing ever
[Music]
i don't see it
we need to see a thumb war match i got
you but hold on a second
now we're ready so i found is the
kenneth
jbpnan and his old thumb related content
i didn't think it was real
it's real here we go the thumb is real
two three four i declare a thumb
oh my god you can't hit me i don't know
if i want to live on the same planet as
that
easy too easy look at that you can't
beat this monstrosity you can't
how do you put it back to normal size
how do you do that
it's a angle his thumb is always long
it's a angle guys it's a angle angles
how do they work how do they work how
are you feeling
oh it's the legend excuse me can i speak
english
you me no english
no program every time happy
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you go
[Applause]
go
[Laughter]
i need to use that oh
so this russian tick tock guy with
father putin's height
is this real i hope it's real it's not
beneath six feet
oh yeah is that real
i thought
[Music]
classic tick-tock love it
[Laughter]
i don't know why this one makes people
laugh so much it's so funny
[Laughter]
it's just but everyone cracks up it's
great
prank done right
oh great wonderful tic tac there's this
super cute guy at the gym
planet fitness greta thunderbird go for
it
i just want to say i think you're really
cute and i was wondering if i could get
your snapchat
[ __ ] no i don't know you just kind of
kind of busted looking
cool i go for more like
attractive got it got it
i mean he did her a favor like anyone
that talks like that to strangers is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and not worth your time anyway yo this
is just a quick reminder that this is
what i look like posing in perfect
lighting with a pump
and this is what i look like in real
life you're a goddamn hero joey you're a
god
damn hero you know women that post
himself
without makeup and everyone going brave
so brave this
this is brave it's just a quick reminder
that this is what i look like posing in
perfect lighting with a pump
and this is what i look like in real
life joey i salute you
i love the comments too dude thank you
so much
wow this makes me feel human first time
i've seen a guy do this
moral of the story always have a pump in
perfect lighting
at all times siri your virtual assistant
i'm siri your virtual assistant i'll
tell you what you're fat little cup
you're boring you don't sound nigerian
at all siri
your virtual assistant you don't sound
nigerian at all
get the [ __ ] out of here oh this is
another garbage
fake ass clip that gets spread on tick
tock
because tick tock is just a cesspool of
fake videos and misinformation
there's no way you'd be able to zoom in
that much and have a steady
steady game it's the american flag
obviously
but here's the problem i can't tell if
they're trolling what in the iphone 200
it's the flag obviously obviously it's
the flag
wait there's wind on the moon
i'm joe biden's husband joe baden
[Music]
hey everyone i'm joel biden's husband
no no he doesn't say jill biden he says
joe biden you can hear it clearly
i'm joe biden's husband you tell me
that's not joker
i like i like how i reacted to like oh
there's so much
misinformation yes this is probably
edited right i'm joel biden's husband
it's funny it's funny i'm sorry
sue me yo did you guys know that if you
plug your headphones into your computer
you'll hear sound but if they're not
plugged into anything you'll hear no
sound
it's because your headphones need to be
plugged in to hear sound
yo did you guys know it's about as
useful as most tick tock tips out there
thank you so much i i always forget it
you know
i don't this hasn't been plugged in the
whole time
i kind of love this and i'll explain why
you want to ask google
to make you a haircut appointment on
tuesday between 10 and noon
so what you're going to hear is the
google assistant
actually calling a real salon to
schedule the appointment for you
let's listen
[Music]
i'll have something else here hi i'm
calling to book a woman's haircut for
our clients
um i'm looking for something on may 3rd
damn it sounds so real too
this is
four what time are you looking for
around
at 12 p.m we do not have a 12 p.m
available
the closest we have for that is a 1 15.
do you have anything between 10 a.m and
uh 12 p.m
finally right after all these robotic
calls
i have to talk to from companies that
call me
we can fight back few companies
i got robots now on my side [ __ ] i'm so
excited
i'm gonna abuse the [ __ ] out of this if
this is real oh
there was a spatula here from when i
made my
my breakfast i have to wonder
my spatula went
[Laughter]
oh thank god he found it he clearly
hasn't seen it keep looking hey stop
harassing the dog
oh the classic i've seen this a million
times but it never gets old
so so far i'm only halfway there it
depends on who the you is referring to
he's not wrong
why are they so quiet can't you just say
ha
true or yeah you're right
[Laughter]
what's your neck name it flies your dice
it depends on the build by the man
since school never taught you how to do
taxes i'm going to you're going to need
taxes i'm going to teach you how to get
a double d manchester bench
this isolated exercise is going to do
that if the plank isn't heavy enough for
you
you can try also a smith machine be sure
to have someone on standby the bench
press is king
so i like to take it slow follow along
with my timing
i left to rise above social construct
like taxes
and death have you seen my [ __ ] chest
bro
i'm not paying mortgage
[Music]
reuse will do
still working on the kiki part but i'll
do the rest my dude
oh it's one of those filter bless you
grandma
what the hell
uh grandma what the hell
it's funny because like i started tick
tock because i wanted to cringe at it
and i find so much cringe
there's also so many great videos i
would never have found otherwise so i
can't really hate on it
again i enjoy the cringe so it's a
win-win
i don't get it what's the problem yes
i'm 31 years old
thank you for watching this video if you
enjoyed the smell and want more smash
like subscribe and i see you in the next
video take care breakfast
[Music]
and you can't go to the zoo did you go
to the [ __ ] loop
i got something
just download it for free for free
download
i got something for you
you